[Music]
hey i'm dave klein i'm jordan remay and
we're here to talk about escape academy
which we just got to check out at summer
game fest 2022 which uh i was really
looking forward to as was i but it was
one of those weird things where i'm like
oh i'm looking forward to this but i
don't actually want to spoil myself on
any of the puzzles and the solutions i
was trying to like
tunnel vision and like not look at any
of the screens as i was walking by it to
other previews this weekend yeah
honestly i was mixed in the sense of i
was looking forward to it but i love
escape rooms i love room escape games i
play a lot of both of them and some of
the room escape video games
are not very good some of them are very
good so i was kind of like cautiously
hoping this would be good and as it
turns out we played together we did the
co-op and it was fantastic i had a great
time it's probably like my favorite
hands-on experience at summer game fest
yeah we played this level where the
water was rising it's kind of like the
start of 999 if you ever played that
water's rising except this time you
actually have a time limit for real and
you have to solve puzzles with that
stressful time limit
and um
it was just fantastically handled and we
were playing co-op and it was like
really being in an escape room with
somebody because i could see your
character we were moving around you
could stream items yeah exactly say it
was one of those things that we were
talking to the devs afterwards and like
oh we made escape rooms before this and
then the pandemic hits we had to like
switch gears because no one wants to do
an escape room when like kovid 19 is
around and they're like oh we now in a
video game setting we can design escape
rooms that like if you did this in real
life like you would be sued so badly
like you couldn't actually trap people
in a place where like oh water is rising
and if you happen to not escape in time
and drown like oh well i guess that
sucks but that's a shame
it's still my dream that one day i'll
wake up and my room is just locked and i
have to figure out how to get out that's
like in my dream situation that's a
bizarre hard dream
so what did you actually think of the
puzzles just brief synopsis i must say i
think
briefly on the puzzles i think it's a
very like good assortment at least the
one that we played of both these logic
based puzzles where you have to be like
okay
you have to get a number between these
numbers here and it's like very
mathematical very like let's think
through this and then as more the
creative puzzles the one that kind of
like reward people who are like oh i can
notice these patterns that not other uh
people do like i thought it was so well
done that we went through this entire
room and there were moments where you
were able to take charge and i was able
to take charge so by the end didn't feel
like well that wasn't really fun it was
basically me just listening today for
the time it was like no it was something
that we were actually collaborating on
and i think that's like the brilliance
of escape rooms the collaboration so i'm
actually curious to see if this game is
as good if you're playing it by yourself
i think like the true
not like genius but like benefit of like
playing this game was having like
someone literally right there with me on
the couch and just bouncing ideas off
like there was a moment where we had to
turn to pen and paper and like start
writing stuff down to be able to figure
puzzles i love that that's awesome like
this is great yeah i thought it was
really intuitively done overall and like
you said it was nice that there were
puzzles that both of us were better at
and that we could kind of bounce off of
each other so it just felt like all the
puzzles were really well thought through
uh that worked in a cooperative sense i
feel like i could do it solo with just
some of them like that you solved right
away would have taken me longer because
it was more intuitive to you
um
but that's what's nice about it and it
just you can actually see the person in
the space with you who you're working
with so you really feel like you're in
that room with them and i'm just really
looking forward to it yeah i was like
what do you what do you think of the
story as say uh and blogs like leading
up to it they said like oh we've taken
inspiration from
uh an anime that's about students
attending a school where like there are
death traps and you're like learning how
to use special abilities ah someone uh
had to help her as a fan of my hero
academia um
like that or food wars or yeah but like
it's the story of like this new student
going to a school that's like just
for like training escape artists and
like learning how to be the escapist
like the number one escapist instead of
trying to be the number one hero and
like it's we didn't get to really see
like much of how that would play out
like the actual story in between the
escape rooms but i am like really
intrigued to like get to that especially
because the art style for this game like
some of the character designs like
they're really unique and really cool
yeah i'm intrigued i don't know if it'll
be the highlight for me whereas like say
999 which i mentioned or virtue's last
reward reward
uh i thought the puzzles weren't as
strong as those games but i absolutely
loved the story of those games i don't
know if
because obviously different team
different writers i like this story as
much but i hope i do on the plus side
though the puzzles were really really
good uh it was a great first impression
yeah like
it's coming out on game pass like
i'm gonna play it like yeah i'm 100
getting it so yeah i just wanted to talk
about it because we both absolutely
loved our experience with it so yeah
comes out for the xbox series x and s
xbox one ps5 ps4 and pc yeah so that
does it for escape academy make sure to
stay tuned to gamespot for more on
summer game fest 2022. we'll see you
guys next time see ya
[Music]